c'est une étape franchie par la police
municipale d'elancourt douze agents ont
reçu une arme de poing individuel un
équipement complémentaire au gilet
pare-balles taser ou encore flash ball
pour ce brigadier ce sera un pistolet
beretta 9 mm pour nous on le prend
vraiment comme un outil de travail
on est conditionné pour travailler avec
une arme
après on sent on s'entraîne nous toutes
les semaines sur la commune d'el en
cours pour avec différents types
d'exercices avec armand les policiers
municipaux ont reçu 45 heures de
formation théorique et pratique sur le
maniement des armes
ils sont passés au crible de
l'administration pour obtenir leur
autorisation
objectif assurer une meilleure
protection de la population
c'est vrai que s'il y a une montée
brutale de tension ou un acte comme on a
vu sur les champs elysées ou ou dans
d'autres circonstances
il s'agit bien sûr qu'il puisse exercer
la légitime défense
compte tenu aussi bien sûr d'un contexte
qui s'est un petit peu dégradée ils sont
formés très sévèrement ils ont il ya un
contrôle de moralité voir c'est une
expérience de maîtrise de formation en
anglais et puis même légalement ils
savent dans quel cadre ils peuvent ou ne
peuvent ou ne peuvent pas bien sûr
sortir leurs armes c c'est extrêmement
cadré
d'autres projets sont en cours le
renforcement de la collaboration avec la
police nationale ou encore le
développement du futur commissariat
d'agglomération à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la commune de
villepreux pourrait aussi armé sa police
municipale avant fin 2017